all right time to have some fun if
you're anything like me
and everyone here at channel 8 you've
been waiting
for the stay with me jc i'm ready
today is the day i checked it out
earlier this week to show you what's
cooking
all right we need a drum roll for this
one bagel mania flagship is finally open
here on convention center drive
and we are going to get a sneak peek of
what is in store hi welcome to sequel's
bagel mania thank you michael i'm so
excited come on in for a sneak peek
i've been waiting for this moment since
i moved here november 2019. oh
yes this is a couple years in the making
you know
vegas does not have anything like this
we saw a need for
authentic jewish delicatessen like this
with a huge restaurant and we're excited
to finally present it to vegas and
everyone from around the world
that will be coming to the convention
center and and vegas yeah and channel
eight because we're right across the
street of course
that's gonna be here every single eight
is always welcome okay so tell us what
we have in store here i see a bar
i see a full service dining room so we
built approximately 200 seat restaurant
has a large dining room private dining
room patio
and of course a bar with gaming you have
to have that in vegas right of course
of course and then the menu i hear it is
a huge one
and a delicious extensive menu we're
proud of it a lot of authentic recipes
as well as some modern twists that we
brought on and we're just super excited
for everyone to
enjoy it okay so we're walking towards
the bakery so everything in our deli and
our bakery
is house baked every single day fresh
homemade starting with our breads we
have challahs double baked rye bread
sourdough wheat
hollow rolls we have unbelievable
pastries from our black and white
cookies to our rugala and of course the
bagels right
we're known for our bagels these are the
best bagels in vegas
quite possibly anywhere in the world all
right all right i'm down to test that
for you
let's do it but before we talk about the
bagels i see pink box
yeah so we do have a little pop-up pink
box we're pretty good friends with the
pink
with the pink box team so yeah you know
we built a pink box that'll be here
every single day
limited menu and we're excited man
bagels
and donuts my two weaknesses this is
gonna be my new favorite place do it
order anything you want all right
let's go with the cinnamon raisin
lots of cream cheese look at that like
magic already made for me enjoy
cheers cheers yeah
that was all cream cheese well i want to
point something out our staff went there
today sally and italia are producers
they all went to bagel maine and they
brought stuff back for everybody
and you ordered a wrap oh come on yeah
because they have that they have
everything they have babies they even
have the little
the little to go place where you just
walk in and you're like okay i just want
that in a little plastic container and
you go so it's really just a one-stop
shop
perfect place every time i move
somewhere i want to have a cheer spot
you know
where everybody knows yeah so that's
going to be it that's going to be my
cheer spot
it's a stone's throw we can throw a
bagel and hit the place that's how close
it
awesome i'm so is we're going to live